car ils prennent forme et bonjour merci
d'être en direct sur rt france alors un
chiffre de 40% est ce que ce mal-être
croissant des soignants vous le
ressentez vous même parmi vos confrères
bien sûr bien sûr on le ressent et elle
ressemble pas seulement récemment en
fait c'est quelque chose qui est là
depuis plusieurs années ça fait
plusieurs années que les soignants
alarme sur le sous-effectif chronique et
la première vague de colis de n'a fait
qu'accélérer une tendance qui était déjà
présente et où on a vu les effectivement
déjà dans l'hôpital public une grosse
vague de départs de soignants de
médecins d'être soignante d'infirmiers
qui juste ne pouvait plus c'était la
goutte d'eau qui faisait déborder le
vase
et aujourd'hui on est face à cette heure
à cette incapacité de nouveau à recruter
des gens il ya une ou par exemple à
marseille une tentative de recruter au
début septembre quand les choses se sont
un peu accéléré un plan catastrophe et
où en fait il y avait plus de personnel
qui voulaient aller là bas parce que les
conditions de travail sont trop dégrader
le sous-effectif chronique
il faut comprendre que ça enlève
absolument tout la nature et tout la
vocation qu'on peut avoir pour ce métier
parce que quand on est en sous-effectif
quand vous avez un infirmier ou une
infirmière pour faire le travail de
trois comme c'était le cas avant ben en
réalité on fait mal et on fait mal aussi
aux patients on maltraite les gens en
moi je l' ai vécu pendant mes études
quand j'étais aide-soignante je
travaille la nuit dans des ehpad et ben
on vous demande de toujours accélérer de
tout
c'est plus vite et plus vous faites vite
et puis vous voyez que vous êtes en
train de faire mal à la personne que
vous essayer d'aider et ça ça vous
retire absolument tout envie de
continuer ce travail ça vous retire tout
toute idée même de votre travail c'est
ya aucune valorisation là dedans n'est
pas là pour ça pour faire mal aux gens
on est là pour les soigner et ça c'est
insupportable
vous avez dit que ce mal-être était
persistante depuis déjà des années bien
avant locaux vides 19 est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus une impression
d'abandon justement pendant la crise
sanitaire
ben complètement c'est à dire que vous
avez d'un côté le discours un peu
officielle et médiatique qui va
consister à caresser dans le sens du
poil les soignants à leur dire qu'ils
sont généreux ce sont des héros etc et
de l'autre côté vous les maltraiter un
exemple concret ben là par exemple le c
ur de la santé a mis sur la table une
augmentation de salaire pour une partie
des soignants une augmentation qui se
dit en passant est ridicule c'est à dire
qu'on était parmi les plus bas en europe
les plus mauvais sur la paye de nos
aides soignants de nos infirmiers et c
est avec cette revalorisation de salaire
du ségur qui n'a pas encore eu lieu il
ya 93 euros maintenant et 93 euros dans
quelques mois
en fait on revient à peine à la moyenne
européenne et d'un côté ils ont lâché ce
que cet argent là mais de l'autre dans
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ils sont en train de le
reprendre
parce qu'il va encore demander des
économies supplémentaires 900 millions
d'économies juste pour l'hôpital avec
7,7 honda cet objectif de national de
dépenses de l'assurance maladie qui a
été créée dans les années 90 est je
crois et qui en fait a complètement
inversé le paradigme de la santé en
france
maintenant en fait on dit on va pas
dépenser plus de temps et puis ben
débrouillez vous pour que ça rend dans
cette fourchette
alors que c'est complètement l'un vers
ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est ce qu'on
faisait avant c'est à dire on soigne les
gens on voit ensuite combien ça a coûté
et on cherche les recettes en fonction
mais là ils veulent plus le faire ils ne
veulent plus le faire ils veulent tout
le temps faire des économies et ça se
fait au prix de la santé des malades et
des soignants et aujourd'hui les
soignants ne n'en peuvent plus n'est
plus un métier attractif on n'a plus
envie de venir d'avoir la boule au
ventre le matin pour venir soigner des
gens est en réalité les maltraiter voilà
voilà ce qu'est la réalité de ce qui se
passe donc aujourd'hui on se sent
complètement abandonnés et ce double
discours ne prend plus il ne prend plus
on voit bien qu'ils se foutent de nous
en réalité il faudrait supprimer cet
ondam 1 puisqu'il le président a dit
quoi qu'il en coûte
et bien alors allons-y de quoi qu'il en
coûte supprimant cet ondam est pure
passons un système comme avant où on a
besoin d'embauchés massives alors on les
fait on a besoin de sang neuf au néant
dans les hôpitaux on les embauche on en
a besoin de 200 milles dans les ehpad
bosch on a besoin de sang ni dans
l'angle à tort on les embauche et on
réglera beaucoup plus le problème de
l'attractivité en mettant plus de
soignants par malade que en lâchant
comme ça quelques quelques euros en
espérant que tout le monde se taise ça
ne peut plus fonctionner en réalité
aujourd'hui faut revenir à l'aise là des
choses ça c'est la loi peut permettre
par des ratios de dire ben voilà vous
avez donc dans un service de réanimation
dans l'infirmier par patient ou dans un
épatant un fermier par patient augmenter
ses ratios il faut les augmenter ça
c'est paris qui peut le faire et ils ont
ils dit aux gars le faire alors on sait
qu' il y à déjà voilà un préavis de
grève pour le 13 octobre qui a été
déposée par la cfdt on l'entend bien le
ségur de la santé compte des angles
morts est ce qu'une renégociation et est
possible avec le gouvernement selon vous
le problème en fait c'est quelle
négociation parce qu'à partir du moment
où ils ont fermé la porte du c'est
durant dix ans de façon va pas parler
d'emblée le jeu en fait un et ils ont
dit on parlera pas de dedans bausch on
parlera pas des si on parlera pas de ça
ils ont annoncé quatre mille embauches
mais c'est en fait ce qu'ils avaient su
filmer les dernières et à côté de ça ils
ont tous concentrés sur les salaires est
aujourd'hui font leur loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale qui est en train
d'examiner qui va être votée
et puis déjà d'ores et déjà condamne le
budget de 2021
c'est à dire que déjà de la prochaine on
sait déjà que ça va pas aller mieux donc
à quel moment de négocier avec ce
gouvernement
en réalité il ya eu il ya une
possibilité maintenant c'est de lui
résister et ce qui nous pend au nez
c'est que effectivement les hôpitaux
soient surchargées non pas à cause du
colis de basses riches et surchargé
chaque hiver les que les soignants sont
ait définitivement est là pour les
rattraper ce sera très difficile
donc aujourd'hui il faut résister faut
aller dans la rue et surtout on a besoin
que le peuple français
se lève avec nous ne nous laisse pas
seuls dans la rue parce qu'en réalité
quand on fait grève dans la santé on ne
fait pas réellement grève parce qu'on
est obligés de travailler pour nous
confie fier de travailler il faut le
comprendre
donc quand on fait grève c'est des
mesures symboliques c'est une mesure de
résistance et c'est un appel au peuple
entier pour qu'ils viennent avec nous
dans les bus et qu'ils gênent dire stop
à cette casse des services publics en
général et de l'hôpital public et de la
santé même en ville merci beaucoup
karim khelfaoui d'avoir réagi sur rtl
france je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste à marseille